好 雖然剛剛明翰也有講
這個半導體展中間
有可能我們會有一點點壓力
不過也正常
因為今天我們真的叫做
領先全世界的大漲
吐回去一點點沒關係
重點是看展看門道
今天就有人動啦
我們一直都覺得
設備股接單滿滿的
怎麼還沒輪到它
看來就是蓄勢待發
有人甚至接近前高
今天你帶來的是
營收有創高
位階還很低的
還有延續著
剛剛聯發科的話題
ESIC要爆單了
我們IC設計族群還有哪些猛將
今天講的這兩個產業
都是我非常喜歡的產業
喜歡到不行
所以我要來跟大家分享
當然我們在看半導體展的時候
我們還是要先搞清楚
台積電在未來幾年
它的先進製程的藍圖
怎麼去做配置
我們今天這一邊呢
基本上把未來大概三到四年的
都已經包起來了
我們現在的這個地方
2奈米嘛
2025年就開始量產
可是大家要知道
台積電的製程節點
不是說2奈米結束以後
然後就往下一步去推
它會針對2奈米去做改良
所以我們看到2026年今年
有所謂的N2U跟N2P
N2P這個東西啊
它就是一個我們說的通用型的強化
那N2U是什麼呢
就是我們在成熟的平台上面呢
再把它做得更好更有效率
到了2027年明年N2X
這個是針對什麼
針對HPC高效能運算的晶片
好那我們除了這些2奈米以外呢
我們接下來還要往A16
甚至往A14去走
因為其實這裡還有一個A16啦
但A16它是第一代導入所謂的金貝供電
就是我們看到這個Super Power Rail
它是第一代
到了A12以後呢
會變成第二代
這個是2028年量產
2029年量產
2030年開始量產
這也就代表的是台積電
已經針對未來四年的製程的那個Raw Map
已經先幫大家寫好
所以台積電能不能再漲四年呢
我們就要看這些製程
合不可以持續的在全球去做領先
一定可以的
一定是可以的啦
這個我是蠻有信心的
当然我们针对的不同的制程里面的话呢
这个是在台积电他们在近期有很多的论坛
我们先把其中的这个蓝图呢
拉出来这是大家最在意的
可是在论坛里面呢
也有提到所谓的意志整合
我觉得大家常常听到这个词
可是又有一点点陌生
这个词听起来就很难懂
很难懂
请你用一个白话文翻译举落
白话文来讲的话就是呢
不同大小的积木
你要把它拼在同一块拼图上面这样子
大概是这样子啦
原因是因为我们知道现在的这个地方中間會有一塊晶片旁邊要放很多的HBM對不對 要放很多HBM甚至你還會有所謂的電源管理IC你有不同的IC可是這些IC它的製程可能不一樣
這塊晶片用2奈米
那你這個地方用的是Dram的製程
你PMIC可能用成熟製程就可以
我要把不同的製程
全部拼到一塊基板上面
這個叫做所謂的抑制整合
大概就是這樣
那現在2025年做的COVAX
是5.5倍的光照尺寸
可是你隨著現在的晶片
它越做越大
它要整合的東西越來越多
到了2029年甚至要做到14倍的光照尺寸
這是一個造證計畫就對了
越造越密
而且精度越來越高
這個東西對於設備來講的話
對於設備廠一定是一個長期的大力多
而我們現在的摩爾定律
大家會想說我們不是已經靠這個
所謂的晶片越做越小
而是你要去搭配這個先進製程
晶片越做越小
背面的供電 晶片供電
HBM
然後做所謂的晶片 3D的去做堆疊
然後CoAX去做封裝
還有甚至連細光子的光電整合
這些把它包成一個系統呢
會形成所謂的新的摩爾定律
它變成是一個系統
而不是一顆晶片來看
所以我們看到了你不同的技術
它其實要對應到的
就是不同的設備廠
我覺得全民的科技知識在這兩三年
因為AI的發展
應該都有大幅的提升
可能是古民對於科技的發展
有知識大幅的提升
以前我們知道成熟製程先進製程
現在還有這麼多名詞
一支整合 經費供電都要了解
特別是我覺得有做股票的投資朋友
那個腦袋不會頓話
要學新的東西
好那我們今天其實要掌握的就是
因為設備股今天G2C聯盟
很多都已經噴出去了
那現在我們要關注的是
營收已經創歷史新高
但是未接還沒有這麼高的公司
有沒有還真的有
所以我們從營收來去幫大家做挑選
在這邊我們去做排列的方式
我們先從鎖定率
也就是從籌碼
這我已經是老朋友了
就是主力券商買的這個股票的集中度
這邊的話就同樣的
我們從基本面
從籌碼面來去幫大家做挑選
我們還是先看一下這個選股邏輯
因為我們前面講過楊誠
好 因為這兩個禮拜前講的楊誠
就漲了17%還在創歷史新高
然後你這邊的話講說
感覺股價創新高
但是外資才剛開始買
確實大戶還在增加
這個就是發哥
其實你對發哥一直不離不棄
給你一個讚
等到回公道了對不對
因為8月25號才剛講
他就得到這個大喜訊了
我覺得在這裡的話
其實我們挑選的邏輯
就是你從基本面出發因為其他的公司他們也一定會像聯發科他為什麼會被揮答入股一定是因為揮答認為他這間公司有價值才願意買他的可轉站不能被別人搶走
不能被別人搶走
所以買好公司的好處就是呢
其他強的公司會往他身上靠
所以我認為陽城其實股價在今天
他一樣創了一個高點
雖然留黑K但是只要股價能創高
代表設備還沒走完
那剛剛明漢哥也講完了
聯發科其實在這裡的話
IC設計ESIC的十年大夢
這個是值得期待的
值得期待的
我還是蠻看好的
我們以設備來講的話
第一間先看6187的萬潤
快接近這個1490的前高
對 快接近前高
那為什麼會在這裡看
第一個是因為它形態這裡
我會把它視為是一個很大的晚行地
這麼大 非常大
它這邊的底部是有打出來
我們從上一次萬潤的法說會
它有提到產能利用率
現在是維持高檔
訂單的能見度是延伸到
2027年的第二季
但不要忘記
這個是現在它的在手訂單
如果後面還有新的訂單進來
這個數字會在一直往後延伸
另外萬潤的話
因為過去從單機的設備
變成他要做整合
我要怎麼樣做一站式的
從貼合點膠
一直到後面的封裝
我能做的我全部一次提供
所以專案價值會提升
更重要的是
細光子的自動光偶合機
萬潤也有相關的設備
因此數字是真的開得出來
以股價的型態來講
距離前高一步之遙
碗形底打好
大戶的籌碼在這邊增加
那對我來講
其實這邊要去創高
我認為其實非常容易
是 非常容易
所以設備長裡面萬潤在這裡
我們當成是一個龍頭的觀察
一旦它能夠創高
其他的設備應該也有機會落後補漲
所以我們第二間公司
我就會看4949的有成精密
好 這一家其實營收很好
非常好 但是股災的時候
可以跌到50幾塊
真是不可思議
我是覺得很委屈啦
但是形態上它有轉強喔
因為第一個
它已經站上了所有的短中長期均線
那再來第二個的話
我們講的是
它在做的是所謂的離子植入
跟MOCVD設備裡面的特殊材料零組件
這個MOCVD是什麼
很多的光通訊啊
大家看到全新啊 聯亞
他們在做的其實製程就是MOCVD
所以這些設備只要持續去做使用
裡面的耗材一定要更換
因此有成精密為什麼會看他
因為他的主要客戶就有台積電
聯電 美光 格羅芳德跟英飛零
全部都是他的客戶
這個時候他的營收數字
上半年獲利EPS2.67
7月年增將近翻倍
這個是創35個月以來的新高
今年法人預估的EPS6塊
可是我們看到他的股價卻只有多少81.7換算下來的話等於是你本益比不到13倍我會覺得以設備股來講這個確實有一點委屈那我們看到的大戶持股也真的有在增加
而且近期外資在這一個月
8月份
是偷偷的在佈局
所以股價今天這一根長紅K
去做表態
站上了季線
它等於是整個心態
對我來講叫做轉多
那量能也真的有在微微的放大
就稍微放大一點
那我認為在這個地方
因為距離前高112
還真的是有一段距離
那我們當純的去參考今年6塊錢的EPS
那如果今天設備能夠給到20倍的本益比的話
其實等於是上方我覺得補漲的空間
還是蠻值得期待
好 當然這個可能也受限於
它是資金上面比較沒有發現到的
不是那種領頭羊指標股啦
有待發掘的寶藏
這個後面就慢慢我們觀察嘛
且戰且走
那當然我們再講到聯發科的話
ASIC這一塊
也是我在年初的時候有強調過
今年一定要看的就是這四個字
ASIC
現在ASIC的話
它的成長速度
事實上是超越GPU
從ASIC目前來講的話呢
你看2026年的預估
差不多一拜一拜
現在我看到的ASIC年徵的速度呢
甚至還會超越所謂的GPU
所以為什麼ASIC會在這邊大幅度的成長
最主要是過去我們一直希望的是
模型的推這個訓練的能力
可是當你模型訓練好了以後呢
大家用AI的人越來越多
我需要的是推論速度的增加
因此這一些CSP大廠
他们采购的结构也会出现变化
2025年呢
可能你的AI ASIC的部分呢
只占了你说采购金额25%到30%
可是到了现在
我模型都训练的差不多啦
我现在要提供的就是
我的客户他需要什么服务
我就针对这个服务去设计晶片
所以ASIC的部分已经占到了
40到50%的采购的这样子的资源
因此在未来只要能够打入ASIC供应链的
应该基本上营收数字
都可以看到未来好几年
那我们以技术进化来讲的话
因為Google的TPU
或者是AWS的Trainment
在今年都已經開始去做
二奈米的頭片跟流片
所以隨著下一代ASIC的產品
他們要用到的門檻提高
又切回去我們前面講的設備
另一方面軟體的部分
在IC設計也會是台灣在下一步
我認為2027年
會是一個大放異彩的一年
因為今年營收數字
像發哥也沒有開出來
可是明年會大幅成長
但是發哥被肯定
回答是有加持的
因為就是不要他被那些
ASIC廠商綁走
沒錯
顯見它是絕對有能力的
但是你說台灣的IE水廠商雖然多
但誰是有能力的
可能我們要鑑定一下
對 因為我們講到了IC設計
〔此段辨識失敗，約 10:00 起〕